three new mobs have been announced for
minecraft for fans to vote on during
minecraft live this weekend battlefield
2042 has revealed its brand new game
mode hazard zone and all of the
competitive playlist details for halo
infinite have been revealed i'm persia
and this is your gamespot news
minecraft live is right around the
corner and after releasing each mob one
by one throughout the entire week we now
know which mobs we get to vote on during
the show each mob has its own bit of
utility that opens new possibilities the
first mob is the glare which can spot
dark areas nearby and flies directly to
them to notify you of potential places
dangerous mods will spawn the light
levels required for mobs to spawn will
be changing in the next update of
minecraft mobs will now require a light
level of zero to spawn which means you
will need a lot fewer torches or light
sources to keep your base safe having a
glare could help you scout out any dark
areas you may have missed while spawn
proofing the alley is a cute flying
friend who will gather items for you
that match whatever item you give it
this mob also loves music and will
deliver the collected items to the
nearest noteblock mini theories around
this friendly looking vex revolve around
its potential usefulness in delivering
items to your storage easy collection
for semi-automatic farms and more for
those who love to sink their time into
mega bases this little friend may be
exactly what you need to help gather all
of those loose blocks that you mine for
your build when your inventory is full
and the third mob is the copper golem
this cute little golem also means the
addition of copper buttons in the reveal
trailer it's noted that the copper golem
loves to press these buttons randomly
which leaves open many creative
opportunities just like copper blocks
the golem will oxidize over time
freezing up after a certain stage it's
unclear if we'll be able to wax them to
prevent this or not just yet but we'll
definitely know more soon all three of
these mobs are super interesting to me
and have so much utility in their own
right i can only imagine how much more
intricate redstone contraptions and
autofarms will become with one of these
mobs on the way which mob are you gonna
be voting for make sure you let me know
in the comments and of course tune in
this saturday because we're gonna be
streaming it right here on our channel
too
ea and dice have officially announced
battlefield 2042's new hazard zone game
mode in hazard zone you play in a four
member squad and your objective is to
locate and retrieve data drives that
have fallen from satellites you'll scour
the landscape for these drives as you
fight against ai combatants and other
teams of human players trying to do the
same thing dai says hazard zone is not a
battle royale mode as the objective is
not strictly to kill other players but
to escape with as many drives as
possible there are gonna be two time
limited extraction opportunities during
the match and the extraction points are
located on two different parts of the
map you and your team can opt to leave
during the first extraction which
happens midway through the match or wait
until the end of the final extraction
it's riskier to wait but you also have
more time to collect drives so the
rewards will be greater in any event
only two squads will make it out alive
or none no matter what only one player
on the team needs to survive and extract
for the entire team to win hazard zone
supports 24 players on ps4 and xbox one
and 32 players on ps5 xbox series xns
and pc so six to eight teams of four
depending on your platform hazard zone
uses all seven maps from battlefield
2042's all out warfare mode and another
thing to note is that each squad cannot
have more than one of the same
specialist character also players who
are killed can be brought back into the
match through a revive system your team
can purchase speaking of purchase hazard
zone has a metagame element too drives
have values assigned to them and
collecting the drives gives you access
to hazards on specific currency called
dark market credits these credits can be
spent to acquire weapons gadgets and
upgrades before matches and honestly
this just scratches the surface of what
hazard zone is all about we have a full
breakdown on everything that it has to
offer on our channel right now courtesy
of our very own david ahmadi so check
that out if you want to know more
a few technical previews have passed and
we've gotten a good look at the social
playlists but 343 has now revealed all
of the competitive settings for halo
infinite i honestly had one simple wish
going into this reveal and it was
granted immediately with br start i know
many players like to have variety and
use as many different weapons as
possible but the br holds a special
place in my heart and i'm happy to see
it back as a starting weapon however
there is no secondary so you will have
to scavenge for a backup when you can
other major changes from the social
playlists will be the removal of the
motion tracker and friendly fire being
on so be careful of those needs weapons
equipment and grenades on maps will
always appear in the same location on
each map and mode combination and will
respawn at the same intervals this is
definitely a classic halo pvp feel that
is going to require teamwork
communication and rotations to set up
for power weapons to succeed in terms of
hit markers only ones for grenades are
set to be disabled in competitive the
modes will include slayer capture the
flag strongholds and oddball for lots
lots more check out 343's in-depth blog
post that runs through everything you
need to know about halo infinite
competitive and if you want even more
competitive halo news well the first in
person halo infinite tournament takes
place in raleigh north carolina this
december and tickets sold out almost
immediately
so many new things are on the way for
these franchises that we love and have
loved for a long time minecraft
battlefield halo do you remember the
first time you ever played these games
and did you ever expect to see them
where they are now let me know in the
comments and of course make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss your next
gamespot news update
[Music]
[Music]
foreign